do you really think that this is the
right thing to do morgan
yes i mean we definitely know that he's
not real you saw what rickshawn said
but now it's just reading the silence
from him do you want that to be us
look we don't know what that is
but there's 28 million people who
deserve to know
[Music]
so from the very beginning this all
seemed too good to be true
just like i did del monte in february
2020 i was contacted out of nowhere
only corresponded over email and men got
footage in the middle of the night for
my first
video i started cutting it but something
about it was just
off yeah of course i had my suspicions
about markiplier i mean
we all did he's kind of a weird guy i
remember back when i was editing game
theory on him
we combed through hours years of footage
you do that with anybody you're bound to
find some anomalies some
erratic behavior even for a youtuber
as i was cutting it something just felt
off
i even asked marcus there's no possible
way that somebody could have faked this
right
just something about the way that mark
was moving against the background
was really bothering me but i've been
editing professionally for over five
years
i was pretty sure it wasn't possible it
wasn't till i started working it
that i realized what was happening
this erratic behavior it didn't stop in
the raw footage
i mean how long can somebody go without
breaking character
and he never broke
except for his nose a few days later i
turned in my cut
but then there were no notes just what
but sure enough the video made it online
and more footage kept appearing so we
just kept chugging along
of course i didn't say anything because
i was the new girl and figured this was
just the norm
i even tried setting up some game nights
as like team building exercises but
he was always mysteriously too busy to
join we lived in la
he lived in la but yet we never saw him
i just thought he hated me but when i
kept not getting fired
i had to think maybe this isn't about
why he doesn't make game nights
and more about could he make game nights
at all
i frequently had mark's audio corrupt
completely and not to mention there'd be
no telling when we'd even get footage in
the first place
and half the time when we did get
footage they were just
empty files but when we tried asking
what was up
radio silence
it got to the point that rachel and i
just couldn't figure this out ourselves
we
needed help we couldn't trust lixian
so we thought maybe the community but we
had to figure out a way of asking them
without
mark catching on so i developed a clever
little code that
slipped right under his nose um
unfortunately though uh the the
community also didn't
exactly understand it and um they
thought it was some big
lore um for the channel so end of the
day we were never closer to the truth
we were starting to think that we were
going crazy
i mean could somebody really be that
fixated on the grinch
can you name another person who likes it
that much and can quote it year round
it just doesn't add up there's something
here there's pieces culminating together
into something i don't understand
but the people deserve to know the truth
even if it lies in madness the world
deserves to know
please if you have any evidence that
mark isn't real post-it to hashtag
markiplier isn't real
we don't have a lot of time